let's go back to the phones 6 1 7 8 3 0
4750 we have a lot of people holding and
let's see where to start maybe with a
local coal I see 6 1 7 8
let's see who's joining us maybe from
here in the Boston area from the 6 1 7
number who's there hello you're on who's
this this is Daniel Daniel what's on
your mind today
hey David so you know recently he came
on the news from The Wall Street Journal
and covered the the deputy the chief
deputy to the Office of Drug National
Control Policy it's called the ONDCP and
it was about the 23 year old college
graduate that you know it was put into
this position
yeah for people who don't know Daniel
just for people who might be listening
and don't know basically there was a
profile done we're like a basically 23
or 24 year old frat boy was going to be
leading the fight against the opioid
crisis for the Trump administration I
could have done it that it was a crazy
yeah so that that's the backstory go
ahead right so you know I work in
addiction industry in Malaya cats when
I'm at the no mile in massive in Boston
yesterday basically when I read this
online I was just totally upset in
heartbroken
mm-hm at the devastation and the deaths
that happened on the basis people's sons
daughters loved ones my loved one other
people I know and for this
administration to put somebody in that
policy making it I'm speechless as you
can tell yeah and I seen over the last
couple of days how close you know
carries even if you want the places
carried it and I really think it really
needs to come to the forefront which is
why I'm on your program because you have
a pretty wide base and it's just it's
just an injustice to every American
whether or not you are affected to this
or not right because it trickles down to
the other people that are hired within
his administration absolutely it I think
injustice is the it's an injustice and
it's disrespectful to the people that
are directly and indirectly affected by
the opioid crisis and I know the area
you're talking about it's very close
to our studio I walk through there
sometimes going out to lunch or to a
meeting and what you see happening out
there is it's not good right it's really
not good and the idea that some 24-year
old frat kid not there's anything wrong
per se with having participated in Greek
life at a university but if you read
into the kids background you would you
would learn a lot more about why he's
probably not the right person to be
leading this it's absolutely horrible
Daniel and I'm glad you brought it up to
me right I mean that we have a clinical
director here we have residential
directors and all these people are
masters level clinicians and just really
highly educated in in regards to policy
as well as you know everything and you
know it's it's it takes decades to
amount this amount of knowledge yeah you
know with in I was just blown away
speechless and you know like I said I
mean in I don't and I you know I know
people don't understand about this
epidemic I know they think it's a choice
I know they think these people are using
their free world to make these decisions
yeah but it's that's not simply not true
and the thing is the addiction is not a
choice but the ignorance is especially
when a lot of the a lot of the auction
daniel is you know is stemming from
originally doctors prescriptions not for
heroin for example or street purchase
drugs but for you know actual doctor
prescribed opioids as well
catches and yep you know everything and
I mean I was at a meeting last night
support group where a vet came back from
the war and he was on opiates and
fentanyl patches for ten years well and
you know in his life is disintegrating
in his marriage and then he decided to
pick up medical marijuana as a choice
you know and I'm listening to this man's
story and he dropped he got off all the
opioids but yet now he's paying for the
medical marijuana out of his own pocket
because it's not covered under any
medical plan it's a circle it gets so
insidious you know and the thing is well
you know I guess when the you know the
corporations get behind lobbyists get
behind the medical marijuana and there's
money to be made and maybe it'll open up
to to other people but that's kind of
not the point of the call but you know
is to get
this is not getting any better by any
stretch of the imagination
agree Daniel Boston you go 50 states you
go to Afghanistan you go to countries
overseas you you know the UK it's
everywhere in but up for our own home
government to take the so lightly then
put Kelly and Conway as the drug czar
are you kidding me yeah it's all it's
all crazy it's a gong show Daniel we
know it and I appreciate you pointing it
out on the program and I do have to move
on but really appreciate the call and
keep up the great work you're doing it's
very very very worthy work I know a lot
of people in the city working on that
issue